you'll never guess what these
celebrities found out about themselves
after taking DNA tests according to a
find your roots segment Julia discovered
that her actual surname is Mitchell not
Roberts Julia also learned that she's
distantly related to actor Edward Norton
George Clooney found out that he is
distantly related to President Abraham
Lincoln they are half first cousins five
times removed a DNA test helped Queen
Latifah track down her ancestors where
she found an emancipation document from
1782 for her fifth great-grandmother
making this the moment that her family
became free from slavery Larry David
discovered that he is related to Bernie
Sanders Larry actually played Bernie
Sanders on an episode of SNL and he
found out that he is his sixth cousin
once removed